[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the latest developments out of the sarah
lawrence college cult federal trial
we're getting into the nitty gritty the
old saying follow the money well the
government is following that buddy and
more than a hundred arrests made as part
of the panama city beach takeover the
behavior of these pathetic cowards that
came to our beach
and committed
these crimes
their actions will not be tolerated plus
a past injustice paves the way for the
future of civil rights i just signed in
the law
the emmett till anti-lynching act
making lynching
a federal hate crime for the first time
in american history but first he pulled
out a gun
and shot me once
twice
directly in the chest the olympian
attempted murder trial where victim
lauren cataract takes the stand law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the trial of former olympian
michael barissone heats up as the woman
who bears own shot twice in the chest
takes the stand as a prosecution star
witness
back in 2019 prosecutors say barrisone
shot lauren canorack in the chest twice
after back and forth arguments about
kanorak's living arrangement at the time
kanarak and her boyfriend robert goodwin
were living on barrisone's property at
the same time barrisone was training her
in dressage horseback riding in the days
leading up to the shooting a string of
9-1-1 calls were made by both parties
barristone saying he tried to evict
canarak and kanarak saying she was being
harassed defense attorneys say barazone
feared for his life at the time of the
shooting and suffered from mental health
issues even sleeping in his stable
leading up to the shooting barristone
was arrested after he shot cataract in
the chest and fired another shot at
goodwin on wednesday she told jurors
what led up to the shooting and how she
reacted in the moments
after i then
was thinking you know all this stuff had
been happening
for the past couple of days
you know michael have been calling the
police on us for reasons that we didn't
even know why
and
not this that it was out of character
um for him to act one way one day and
then
you know be nice the next day
but
i kind of wanted to know so i
walked over to him
and said
you know
how do you plan to make this better how
do you you know you have
a bill or some i was
saying something about
the bill that he had to settle with rob
but i didn't get that far
because why not
the minute i started talking pretty much
or
yeah within the minute i started talking
he pulled out a gun
and shot me once
twice
directly in the chest
do you
remember how he was holding the gun
was it close to his body or pointed out
and held away from his body
it was kind of like
he pulled it out
pointed it
boom
boom
just like that
can you tell the jury
what you remember seeing
or hearing
when he fired the gun i remember seeing
my chest
um
why'd you look at your chest
it was almost unreal to me
that
i just gotten shot so i looked at my
chest quickly
see
are there really holes there like
this this can't be real
um i also then saw
michael raise his arm up
and shoot at robert who was on
the porch still just directly raised his
arm
shot at robert
and then robert disappeared
at that point
i saw michael run around me and go
running up the stairs of the porch
ahead of canorax testimony jurors heard
from ruth cox the woman whose gun
bearisson used to shoot cataract she
told jurors canarak knowingly did not
follow the rules of the stable
she would cunt she and he would come at
odd hours during the night and do
exactly as you said turn all the lights
on in the stable turn on the music
which
in for the horses they should have quiet
and peace at night and not be disturbed
because they are very busy during the
day
and um
that was that was the routine that was
asked to be done at the stables is after
eight o'clock that there'd be nobody up
there in the stables
all right joining us today is former
detective and swat member lisa lockwood
and terry austin lisa canorack took the
stand and was even cross-examined so how
did she hold up
she did great under uh with the
prosecution because they were able to
get out her story without any
interruption where she was able to
explain exactly what happened defense
attorney however had been admonished
multiple times regarding his course of
questioning and a lot of time was spent
on audio recordings where she was
attempting to audio uh tape barristone
and find out what he was saying so i
feel
right now as far as where where this is
headed uh prosecution has a great case
she's a victim she's a witness and she
can tell her story
exactly as it happened and i think she
held up very well yeah and she's
survived two shootings so or two shots
sorry so that that that's amazing for
the prosecution to get out there now
terry self defense is largely about
reasonableness but how does that work
when you factor in barasson's mental
health
you know what i actually think that the
defense is doing pretty well so far i
think first of all the jury is looking
at this and thinking the judge is being
very difficult as far as the defense
attorney is concerned he's doing the
same thing the prosecution's trying to
do and the judge is stifling him i think
as far as lauren canaric is concerned
she was taunting him and it was very
clear on those questions that she posted
a lot on social media and then at the
time we know that barrosone probably
knew about the social media knew she had
a gun knew she was threatening him and
once she physically approached him
maybe he was thinking she was going to
attack him maybe she had the gun and he
was in self-defense shooting her and he
shot her and she survived look no excuse
for shooting anybody but we just saw
that in florida someone with popcorn won
a case and was acquitted so who knows
what this jury is going to do the
interesting part though terry is a lot
of the information you're talking about
can only come from one person so maybe
barristone takes a stand and maybe
that's his only saving grace in this
case of course we'll be following this
case for capital gavel coverage and give
you the updates as they come out
still ahead on law and crime daily
spring break takes a dark turn when
dozens of people are arrested in panama
city beach florida but first more than
half a century after his tragic murder
emmett till is forever immortalized when
an anti-lynching act is signed into law
[Music]
welcome back historic legislation was
signed by president biden the emmett
till anti-lynching act making lynching a
federal hate crime in america for the
first time ever congress attempted to
pass similar legislation over 200 times
before this one finally moved forward
this year the bill's namesake emmett
till was a 14 year old black teenager
from chicago who was abducted tortured
and shot in 1955 after a white woman
claimed he whistled at her at a store in
mississippi while visiting his family
the woman's husband at the time and his
brother were tried for his murder but
acquitted by an all-white jury the two
later admitted to his killing till's
mother used his funeral as an example to
shed light on racism in the u.s and the
barbarism of lynch of lynching president
biden spoke to reporters shortly after
signing the bill on tuesday
between
1877
and 1950 more than 4
hundred
black people were murdered by lynching
most in the south but some in the north
as well
that's a lot of folks man and a lot of
silence for a long time
lynching was pure terror
to enforce the lie
that not everyone not everyone belongs
in america not everyone is created equal
terror to systematically undermine
hard-fought civil rights
terror not just in the dark of the night
but in broad daylight
innocent men women and children hung by
nooses from trees
bodies burned and drowned and
castrated
their crimes
trying to vote
trying to go to school
to trying to own a business or preach
the gospel
false accusations of murder arson and
robbery
simply being black
back to break down this landmark
legislation is former detective lisa
lockwood and terry austin terry i've
seen this bill referred to as largely
symbolic but with some serious teeth
what are your thoughts on it
listen brian there's no question this is
a significant piece of legislation it
actually recognized the history of
racial violence in this country and
that's important it sends a message that
any of these people who are engaging in
this type of crime will
have significant punishment of at least
30 years so basically what it's saying
is that whoever conspires to commit a
hate crime offense that results in death
or serious bodily injury and they
haven't received due process that
individual they could be in prison for
30 years what i really like about this
brian is that it was a bipartisan vote
we know only three republicans did not
vote for it in
the house and it was unanimous consent
in the senate
good backing great bill glad it happened
absolutely now lisa how do you think
this law would have affected cases like
the death of george floyd or even a mont
arbory
definitely i think it would affect the
amount arbory case because we know what
happened there we had three three
individuals who were pursuing a man who
they thought was stealing and ended up
executing this man and they all had
weapons just because he didn't stop no
due process whatsoever they took the law
into their own hands one of the things i
also researched is hate crimes in 2020
alone 11 000 hate crimes were committed
61 were based on race alone of those 61
how many would have benefited from this
new law with anti-lynching on top of it
as an enhancement so i think it's
necessary and the national attention
surrounding this is important as a
deterrence it needs to stop absolutely
well hopefully this law never needs to
be used hopefully lynching is not
something we ever see in this country
again but it is there to be enforced and
hopefully stops others from doing it
coming up on law and crime daily the
latest developments in the sarah
lawrence colon sex cult federal trial
plus more than a hundred arrests put a
damper on a panama city beach spring
break vacation why officials call the
suspects quote cowards who hid behind
guns
[Music]
welcome back a spring break vacation
gone wrong as more than 100 arrests are
made and 75 weapons are recovered as
part of the so-called pcb takeover it
started as a social media phrase
indicating the takeover of panama city
beach florida during the spring break
participants of this social media event
would gather at spring break house
parties concerts block parties or beach
events many of which carrying weapons in
all 161 people were arrested in
connection to the takeover the majority
of the arrests stemmed from illegal
firearm charges and all 75 weapons were
recovered by law enforcement all of
which were possessed illegally in a
press conference the bay county sheriff
said law enforcement used technology
like license plate readers and cameras
to get ahead of the suspects
this is an event that we've been
planning for um and gathering
intelligence on for two or three weeks
and i think that's been a success and it
allowed us to target the bad guys and
know where they were
be there before they got there be there
after they got there and target them and
put them in jail we can't control
who comes to town i said this yesterday
but we can control
what happens to you when you commit a
crime in this town
in front of you
you see a representation
of
the danger
facing our community
and our law enforcement officers
these guns were taken
over a period of two days
it could arm a small army
semi-automatic weapons long rifles
these are weapons brought to a resort
destination these were weapons brought
to a beach
by cowards that hide behind these guns
by cowards that cried when they were
approached by true heroes wearing a
badge
these individuals will soon find out
what justice looks like in bay county
the individuals that carry these guns
will find out
what happens when you commit a crime in
bay county
it will not be tolerated
former detective and swat member lisa
lockwood and co-host terry austin are
back to break down the bust of the pcb
takeover terry do you think this model
can and will be replicated in other
spring break or large party venues and
can it help to limit crime generally
well you know it's a really strange
situation i do think if local
communities like you know panama city
city beach if they've experienced this
type of criminal behavior where people
come into the community they have guns
they're stealing they're robbering
they're threatening people i think if
you know that's going to happen you
should defend your city you should use
social media you should plan to be ready
for any such attack or that type of
behavior frankly i haven't seen that
type of behavior before but i do think
that their response the authority's
response to this was right on point if
in fact they've had that issue before
yeah now lisa we're just hearing a
snippet of how big this bust is can you
give us a bigger picture or some
background as to how large an operation
like this must have been to capture so
many guns
well we know it was a joint agency
operation there were four agencies
involved everywhere where from florida
highway patrol to bay city sheriff's
office and panama city beach and pd as
well they seized high-powered weapons
high-capacity weapons they use the intel
like he said license plate readers they
also i guarantee you
aside from 600 citizen phone calls they
had tip-offs they had informants they
have people who are already in custody
but the biggest tip-off were the
offenders they talked about this online
they planned this big takeover it was
there it's they knew who was coming so
it was just a matter of time to get them
all together in one place one house get
the promoters and have this incredible
seizure that they did
absolutely hopefully it keeps spring
break in panama city beach just that
much safer for everyone thank you both
when we come back the accused leader of
the sarah lawrence college cult stands
trial in federal court long crime
network's adam classville brings us the
latest testimony from inside the
courtroom
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
testimony continued wednesday in new
york federal court in the case of
accused sarah lawrence sex code leader
lawrence ray the focus shifting from his
alleged victims to the investigation
into race finances ray faces several
federal charges including racketeering
sex trafficking and money laundering
among others in relation to starting an
alleged cult with his daughter's college
friends and some of their siblings
dating back to 2010. prosecutors allege
ray used fear and manipulation to get
his alleged victims to feel that they
owed him and would use different means
to get them to pay him back court
exhibits share insight on testimony of
victims saying they asked friends and
family to loan them money one of rey's
victims claudio jury testified he forced
her into prostitution and ended up
giving him millions of dollars on
tuesday an fbi forensic accountant took
the stand telling jurors of this
complicated web of ways money trickled
in from jurors clients and other outlets
long crimes adam classville is following
this case from inside the courtroom he
brings us an update on the latest
testimony
the government's case appears to be
winding down and we're getting into the
nitty-gritty the old saying follow the
money well the government is following
that money including the 2.5 million
dollars that claudia drury says that she
made for larry ray from sex work her
finances appear in a series of charts
that were scrutinized by an fbi forensic
accountant it doesn't go into all of the
2.5 million dollar number but it does
provide a portrait of it and it shows a
common theme over the course of 15 pages
of the document that were analyzed for
the jury it shows that
much of this money
went to larry ray's go daddy account
where he had this domain name business
that prosecutors say was his method of
laundering the money it's pretty
eye-popping when you look at these flow
charts they
had more than 1 000 transactions
totaling nearly a million dollars and we
still have to hear the defense case as i
said the government appears to be
winding its case down we may
though we don't know hear from mr ray
himself after that i suppose we'll hear
closing arguments and then the case will
go to a jury that will consider 17
separate counts charged against him
lisa adams said it best follow the money
but is that just a saying or is it true
both in real life and this trial
oh without a doubt this is this is real
life having a forensic audit on his
godaddy accounts showing over a million
dollars in revenue that's where he
laundered the money also finding out
with the prostitution ring that he was
running the young lady said it was in
excess of 2.5 so where else aside from
godaddy was he able to launder this
money it was a unique way something
completely different but criminals are
always looking for different ways to go
ahead and
layer their money find banks to transfer
money to get cash into the system where
they're not audited by taxes so thank
god for the the laws regarding
racketeering he extorted money also did
money laundering on top of the other 16
charges that he has regarding the abuse
and the sex cult uh the list goes on so
uh this is something that is there's a
story like i've never seen before
yeah this is this is definitely one i've
never seen either terry we've talked
about this before what do you think of
the order of the witnesses for the
prosecution do you think ending on the
finances leaves a strong enough punch or
does it even matter with all of the
testimony we've heard so far
i do think the strongest strategy for
any prosecution is to begin strong and
to put in the less interesting
information in the middle and then to
end strong so there are a number of
victims here who could have started and
we did see that we know for a fact that
felicia rosario and and her brother
santos rosario were two of the victims
here and of course claudia drewery was
on the stand for quite some time but
what i would have done is to put the
finance people and lisa is right it's
very important to follow that money i
would have put them in the middle and
then ended probably with claudia drury
because her testimony was extremely
compelling and she talked about the
money
yeah i agree that that would have been a
strong end to have claudia jury there
well thank you both as well as you thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you